on se trouve ici devant le chantier de
la salle paristech nos locaux actuels
sont situe à malakoff et donc nous
allons déménager dans un an sur le
plateau de saclay ce bâtiment il nous
permettra d'accueillir davantage
d'étudiants environ 700 800 étudiants
contre 500 actuellement des
enseignants-chercheurs et donc d'être au
sein du plateau de saclay un pôle pour
l'économie la sociologie les sciences
sociales et les sciences des données
l'origine du projet c'est un c'est un
concours d'architecturé qui a eu lieu en
donc avec mes associés bitat azimi et
marc godinot nous avons gagné ce
concours c'est un bâtiment qui fait
seize mille 7000 m² donc sur sur un
rez-de-chaussée 4,4 au niveau donc
c'était à la fois de créer un petit vide
clos d'un d'un cloître
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui plaît beaucoup
aux chercheurs et puis d'abord un
bâtiment aussi qui s'ouvre totalement
sur le paysage sercan fait en vaut
toutes les façades sont vitrées à 100%
nous ce qui nous intéressait donc
c'était à la fois de mettre en dialogue
le bâtiment par sa structure qui est une
exhaust rupture métallique en résonance
avec avec les arbres avec le bois avec
les troncs avec la nature et puis aussi
donc de rendre ce bâtiment extrêmement
flexible c'est à dire aussi de penser à
peut-être dans une vingtaine d'années où
avant ou plus tard que ce bâtiment
pourrait se transformer paris saclay
c'est pour nous un espace de partenariat
quasiment sans équivalent en france le
déménagement va clairement nous
permettre de nous rapprocher de nos
partenaires que sont l'école
polytechnique hec l'école normale
supérieure de cachan et l'université
paris sud et les organismes de recherche
les autres établissements qui qui sont
sur le plateau déjà au qui ont vocation
à y déménager dans les prochaines années